hi I'm relief from free code camp today  we are going to talk about what is a  network  so before we answer that question let's  take the example of two people who are  trying to communicate with each other so  what happens here when one person talks  he is creating vibrations in the air  which is the medium and these vibrations  reach the other party and that's how two  people communicate so one person talks  and the vibrations travel through the  medium and reach the other person who is  listening now in case of two computers  how do they talk they don't have mouths  yet or they can't create vibrations in  they're in the air so how do they talk  so here what we have to do is we need to  create some sort of connection between  these two computers so a connection  between two or more computers or more  devices to communicate between them is  called a network